Speaker 1: The Trump family doesn't have a
great track record when it comes to charity
and donations.
Trump often promising donations, which he
never gives.
We've talked about the Trump Foundation or
whatever it was called, having to stop operating
as part of an agreement based on an investigation
into the fraudulent nature of that.
Well, Melania Trump is now getting pulled
into it.
A Melania Trump event is being investigated
after promising to donate proceeds to a charity.
Speaker 3: Uh oh,
Speaker 1: that doesn't appear to exist.
A charity event set to be hosted by Melania
in Florida is being investigated after organizers
said a portion of its proceeds would go to
a charity that does not appear to exist, per
the New York Times.
The organizers have said the high tea event
in April in Naples, Florida, will benefit
fostering the future a be best initiative
granting computer science scholarships to
those aging out of the foster care system.
Tickets are three grand VIP.
Tickets are 50 grand.
We don't know what percentage would go to
charity, but what's the real problem?
The real problem is the New York Times found
no charity with the name of fostering the
future or best registered in Florida.
Now, you might say, Well, maybe they're just
not registered, but in Florida, the law requires
that organizations soliciting donations register
so that you know it's a real charity.
Consumer services division is currently investigating
whether this event involves an entity operating
in violation of Chapter 496 Florida statutes.
Melania Trump denies that the charity doesn't
exist.
The New York Times, of course, reported this
initially enough people following up following
the launch of her line of NFTs and the auction
of a white hat she wore at the White House.
She's selling tickets for this April 9th event
in Naples.
The tulips and topiary is high.
Tea is pitched as a once in a lifetime experience,
an afternoon of sophisticated, elegant set,
an elaborate, lush floral gardens designed
to inspire giving hope, possibility and dreams.
There's no indication of how much money will
be raised, and Melania says the reporting
that the charity doesn't exist is false, she
tweeted.
Dishonest reporting.
Added Again, everything has been done lawfully
and all documents are in the works.
Read with caution.
Typical corrupt media.
She added she's working with the Bradley Impact
Fund, which calls itself a donor advised fund
for conservatives.
Does it exist or not?
We don't know.
But it has real human fund vibes.
I don't know how many of you guys are, you
know, Seinfeld fans, but there is an episode
in which the George Costanza character starts
asking for donations to the human fund, which
is fake.
It's just him.
It's him.
It's, you know, money for people is the slogan,
and the money just goes to George.
And this is just apparently with Melania,
the continuing grift upon grift upon grift
that has been the Trump presidency.
The campaign he ran was a grift, and then
the presidency was a grift.
And then the fundraising in order to overturn
it was adrift.
It's all a grift, and it now involves Melania
Trump.
And is the charity real or not?
Well, it's certainly not registered with the
state of Florida.
That alone is enough to make it all against
the law.
They will never stop unless someone stops
them.
I hope that you will all join me.
Tuesday, March one Now just about 10 days
away for Joe Biden State of the Union address,
this is expected to be one of the most consequential.
State of the Union addresses in a long time
for a number of different reasons, will Joe
Biden signal the end of the pandemic phase
of COVID?
What will be going on with Ukraine, Russia?
What will be signaled about the 2022 midterms,
which themselves will be so consequential
for 2020, for major major State of the Union
address?
We will be live on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook
starting one hour before the speech.
I hope you will join me and stick around today.
We'll be taking some of your calls.
I'll be reading some of your emails and so
much more to discuss.
Follow me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know what you think about Melania's
so-called charity.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer supported
program, a listener supported program, you
can sign up and get a membership at join Packman
dot com.
Extremely exciting thing to do.
You can also
use the coupon code WOUD 22 for a discount.